on va se balader un petit peu sur le net
si je vous dis mario amélie youtube
youtube j'ai un garçon de 14 ans a fait
ce que vous avez trois enfants h
précises
ok donc bah voilà youtube vous en avez
un exemple ici avec toile si je dis que
paul guez fait le buzz c'est l'info bon
voilà ouais on peut enfin je gbh à 250
milles abonnés sur youtube je totalise
environ 10 millions de vues avec en
dessous de mes vidéos puis certaines
vidéos comme par exemple le maroc qui
font 2 millions de vu des choses c'est
énorme quand on y pense
et voilà plusieurs vidéos qui athènes ce
million de vues et donc voilà donc je
sais pas si on peut parler de buzz mais
en tout cas c'est court c'est percutant
c'est rigolo et c'est à voir en images
on en parle juste après on regarde tous
ensemble vous allez me dire ce que vous
en pensez
salut à toutes et à tous je vais finir
une année de terminale il ya pas mal de
choses à dire sur cette place tout donne
en tout temps les mecs c'est pas
possible c'est un droit mais c'est
chiant c'est redondant à la fin tu peux
pas faire une vidéo sur la terminale
t'es qui toi comment ça je lui dis tu me
reconnais pas si le pôle de 2017 qui a
fait une vidéo sur la première ouais
mais je m'en fous toi si je veux parler
de la terminale je parle de la terminale
mais mec ton originalité elle est passée
au et toi tu crois que ton original
t'es qui toi symbole je vois qu'on
oublie schiphol de 2007 qui a fait une
vidéo sur la comédie tout ce que je peux
te dire mec c'était pas plus original
que le pôle de 2018 espèce de conte
comment son espèce de con et tu fais
trop loin toi tu ne dis quelque chose
commence à chauffer la loi est un film
mr que tu sais pas qui je suis quoi de
quoi a dit 2017
steeve estatof une millions pour moi
avec ta vidéo est moins que d'un milan
que tu parles d'un livre de mer voyage
est muet depuis je me devais finir la
série de vidéos sur l'iss est d'avoir
une trilogie vient donc maintenant vous
me laisser tranquille et je fais ma
vidéo sur la terminale merci à tous et
bon tournage fait les mecs
merci bref il fallait que l'on finisse
avec ce lycée bon alors on va rassurer
maman qui n'est pas très loin
vous continuez vers l'école de commerce
vous lancer à fond dans youtube on va le
choix a été assez vite fait fin comment
dire je pense faire une prépa hec
d'abord pour préparer justement une
grande école de commerce
parce que voilà on sait que ce milieu
c'est un certain quand même on peut pas
en vivre directement j'ai envie de dire
donc et puis je suis assez attiré par le
cinéma aussi parce que c'est une de mes
passions j'adore la réalisation de
vidéos jouer tout ça mais je pense qu'il
faut être assez lucide et m'assurer déjà
un diplôme avant pour après pourquoi pas
mais les le commerce je sais pas à créer
une start up mêlée à youtube et les
flammes and the pool alors moi j'ai une
maman et un papa donc forcément la
réaction de la maman d'abord c'est pas
la maman de paulin je précise voilà là
des enfants
moi j'ai un petit 12 enquêterait youtube
est ce que je pourrais te demander de
faire une vidéo comique pour expliquer
aux plus petits toits aux plus jeunes
qu'eux effectivement il faut aussi
travailler à l'école avoir des envies et
tout ça et que on peut faire ce qu'on
veut mais que c'est plus facile si on
je pourrais passer une commande
peut-être malheur je vais passer mon
replay ce qui va me dire à mon fils de
11 ans voilà en replay toute la journée
à achat va comprendre que que l'école
était pourtant way du taux à moins de 17
ans en fait et c'est d'autant plus
important que derrière ça il ya du
boulot
j'imagine qu'elle la préparation ça se
fait pas comme ça en claquant des doigts
quoi c'est ça va énormément de travail
moi j'étais pas pour une vidéo bien
travaillé je dois passer au moins 100
heures honnêtement sans heurt dessus
pour ce que je fais tout jeu j'écris je
tourne et vidéo je réalise après je
monte le montage tu fais tout seul tout
seul il ya mais il ya mes amis qui
viennent m'aider quand même pour tourner
pour tenir la caméra il mais après pour
ce qui est là par exemple comme ça je
sais moi qui fais tous les idées mais ça
c'est bon c'est bon faut pas croire que
cela se fait comme ça mais non c'est ici
puisqu'on parle de chiffres pour fêter
le sang min m abonnés sur sa chaîne
youtube put été lancé un défi
ouais moi j'avais demandé à mes abonnés
que si un jour parce que c'est un rêve
qui est en quelque sorte d'atteindre les
100 kg n'est que si justement
j'atteignais ce cap
je sauterai en parachute et il se trouve
que j'ai atteint ce cap donc que j'ai
que tu veux voir tout de suite en direct
allez on vous fait elle pensait
personnellement je trouve que je
ressemblais cochon
alors là quand même c'est spectaculaire
bond la 10e rang parachute tu te balades
toujours avec de quoi filmer non non non
quand même pas dans la rue des fois on
me reconnaît dans la rue mais je veux
dire donc que pourquoi pas ici il me
faut quelques vidéos et prennent une
photo mais sinon non je ne te promène
pas avec la caméra ça ça doit aider pour
draguer sa n'ont alors d'autre voie j'ai
fait une vidéo séduire une fille
justement qui fait aussi son milieu je
crois ah oui et non on vous conseille de
pause des copains justement il en pense
quoi
mes amis ouais bah ils sont fiers de moi
ils sont contents là ils me regardent
ils sont en cours parce que là je sèche
du coup je pense qu'ils vont dire
l'arrêt car son qui regarderait donc je
leur ai je les salue d'ailleurs mais oui
ils sont contents et puis surtout moi ma
chaîne je fais surtout avec eux enfin je
m'éclate avec eux avant tout c'est
surtout je rigole je me marre donc que
je les invite avec moi non mais parce
que là on a deux exemples on attend que
quasiment tout seul et la plupart des
titres audio et la télécopie ou qu'il
vole la vedette
mais c'est la famille il en pense quoi
la famille derrière moi aussi mes
parents super fier ma mère dans le
château et puis non ils sont voilà que
ce soit ma grand mère mon grand-père qui
doivent me regardez d'ailleurs jusque
dans les salles us et que leur prénom
c'est chantal et aux régies ce qui va
regarder la tu me regardes moi tu dis
bonjour à chantal et régis suis sûr
qu'on va faire un joli plan sur toi ok
voilà un bon jour chantal
j e me salue pas pu quand même